oh wyd again hello and welcome to this
video playing some la from Austria so
let's transpose I don't mind this maybe
get into a peroxy bind all of a sudden
yeah 57 all night 64 other Lane moves
should be 7i go nite c2 with this one
that's rare that's rare let's scrap this
and see where it leads to the light
squares look look difficult for like
difficult maybe the wrong words look
they're problematic not sure this is a
very direct way of doing it something
like f4 certainly wasn't too bad either
so Nancy 5c if I'm actually BTW xe5 so
not that great
cue creepy three probably wasn't the
absolutely best idea so we've got night
a five coming up tween a form hmm let's
see quickly eight I don't have a very
clear idea what to do here
oh ok I know that doesn't really
threaten all that much well maybe I'm
threatening night a seven the Queen
isn't doing much won't be free so okay
so these are taking this so let's go
before a seven now is hanging absolutely
maybe black can actually go 85 here i
don't know i had permanently weakens
like everything doesn't look like a good
woman a 60 because i cannot take it oh
and this blunders the night 94 it's not
yeah i wasn't exactly my dream scenario
but yeah it's what it is i have to be a
little bit cautious that matt bishop is
not turning into a really bad pc and
this position it already looks a little
bit looks a little bit problematic okay
if I take now that's not good right
let's keep the Queen John oh maybe I
could have shaken taken be success he
was hanging of course but still so
what's this I can take this I'll take it
[Music]
correct the porn funds on your ok let's
go back and now how to how to play and I
shall be five maybe 97 but I think 97 I
can go see if I always loved doing
anything against
[Music]
maybe I just a tech a fire and grab it
grab stuff aki clap for it just like
took everything that you offered to me
and now let's see how you can get those
pawns and moving
you know what to do maybe traitors let's
trade it huh yeah yeah non-winning stuff
that's even better black hey guys okay
so yeah it should be six is a somewhat
strange move i have to say even though I
definitely did not refute it and I know
Quinn d3 probably doesn't do all that
much yeah the engine has this this thing
on the jack the gender but I didn't
quite oh I can take this pawn okay that
makes it interesting otherwise this
wouldn't be strategically all that
desirable but if I can grab this that's
good it was ha ok ok the way I played it
not much happened again c5 because the
pond is hanging I didn't see that at all
can use the engine was a suggestion oh
ok and now he was ok i think is nothing
nothing terrible about the position and
he I expected him just to take and play
five as the engines can also suggest
here blanka's idea would be chill maybe
we would deny to deform I'm not sure
that he manages that actually because
I'm going to have some things that are
attacked so home engine says equal that
could be right now yeah I mean I could
have taken also what this is good for a
while as well they just then was far too
generous with this poll
and ultimately just not working check
and blunder Duke and he has to probably
take hwy five and then I play I fall of
Queen B Phi he actually hey to hang
maybe just back why does two points up
it's not so easy though and so on some
work like have some hopes so the night
could come here the bishop card is not
all that great iam that's still
something that I have to convert for us
not not all that easy ok guys thanks for
watching